Miranda's Maid Service charges
$280 to clean 8 offices.
What is the company's price for
cleaning a single office?
So they charge $280 to
clean 8 offices.
So it's $280 per every
8 offices.
And then we can simplify this.
We could see, well,
are both of them
divisible by a common factor?
And this one looks like
it is divisible by 8.
200 is divisible by
8, and then 80 is
divisible by 8 as well.
So let's divide both the
numerator and the
denominator by 8.
And if we do that, 8 goes
into 28 three times.
3 times 8 is 24.
Subtract.
You have 4 left over.
8 minus 4 is 4.
Bring down this 0.
8 goes into 40 exactly
five times.
5 times 8 is 40, and you
have no remainder.
So when you divide 280
by 8, you get 35.
And if you divide 8
by 8, you get 1.
So this rate simplifies to, this
price per office, I guess
we could call it, simplifies
to $35 for every 1 office,
which we could also write as 35
over 1 dollars per office,
which is the exact same thing
as $35 per office.
And we're done.
That is the company's
price for cleaning a
single office: $35.